hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
palindromic substrings and this is
another problem from the leak code
blind 75 list a list of 75 very good
leak code problems to solve and this
time we will be doing palindromic
substrings down here
and so we are getting one step closer to
filling out this entire list and this
problem palindromic substrings is
actually really similar to another
problem i've solved
longest palindromic substring so if you
would like to i'd recommend watching
this video as well longest palindromic
substring i will probably link it in the
description below
so simply we are given a string s and we
just want to return the total number of
palindromic sub strings contained in the
string s
and as you may know a palindromic
substring
is basically a string that can be read
backwards and it's the same string so
you know a
a if you read it backwards it's the
exact same string right
a b a you know this is the same string
reversed
you know because the first character is
the same as the last character
and then in the middle we're just left
with one character and
you know basically that kind of pushes
us towards a base case so
as you may know there's two types of
palindromic substrings
strings of odd length right so for
example just a single letter a
that's a palindrome right it's it's the
same backwards
if we add a b to the beginning and a b
to the end it's still a palindrome
because now we
expanded it outwards with the exact same
character
similarly we can do the same thing with
even length sub strings as well if we
have two a's
in the middle then of course this is a
palindrome and then
if we continue to expand outwards we add
a b at the beginning
and we add a b at the end it's
continuously
going to be a palindrome because these
characters are also matching now if we
instead of adding a b we added a
c at the end the inside is a palindrome
this string of length
two but now if we expand outwards this
is not a palindrome right yeah this just
it can't be read backwards c is not the
same as b it's not a palindrome
so that's a little bit about palindromes
even an odd length
but so how can we apply that to our
input
so in this case we are given a string a
b c now of course we have three
different
palindromes because each character by
itself is a substring of course
and each of those by themselves is a
palindrome as well so that's three now
is any other substring for example a b
that's not a palindrome
bc that's not a palindrome abc that's
also not a palindrome that's basically
all the substrings available to us
so we only find three so we're going to
return three so let's
understand how we can do the brute force
solution which is actually big o of n
cubed and then we can actually optimize
it a little bit understanding how even
an odd palindromes work
and then we can get a big o of n squared
time complexity solution
so let's say we're given a string that
looks like this
if we just start brute forcing it we
want to go through every single
substring right so every single
substring starting at this first
position would be something like this
right
there's these substrings right then we'd
want to go through every single
substring starting at this position
which would look something like
this right in total there's going to be
n squared sub strings right
and for each substring for example you
know this
one we need to determine if it's a
palindrome or not and we know it you
know that's not
a difficult algorithm to write we could
have two pointers one at the beginning
one at the end
we basically keep comparing the
characters and making sure that they're
the same right so
and for a substring like this we'd also
have two pointers right compare that
okay these two
characters are the same so then we can
move inward right we'd shift our
pointers here
and then we'd see okay this character is
also the same and then you know we we go
through every character so we determine
yes that's a palindrome then we can
increment our count of palindromes right
we'll call that our result variable
so then we'll add one to it right
because that's ultimately what we're
trying to return the number of
palindromic substrings inside of this
string s and clearly finding and
determining that a string
is a palindrome is also big o of n
so since there are n squared substrings
in the entire string
s and for each of those substrings we
have to determine that it's a palindrome
we're going to multiply it by n so this
is going to give us an
n cubed time complexity now we can
improve this
and it's going to require us to solve
this problem in a different
order what we're instead going to do is
we're going to go through every single
position in
this right instead of finding for this
position all the substrings that
start at this position we're going to
find all the sub strings
that this position is the middle of so
instead of you know just going to the
right we're actually going to expand in
both directions we're going to go
through
all sub strings where this position is
the middle position
now clearly this string itself is one
string right and
this is a palindrome so we're gonna have
our left and right pointer just
initially at this position
we're gonna see that okay both of these
characters are the same right so then we
can take our result
add one to it right so we found so we
did find one palindromic substring
and then we're going to try to expand
outward right our left pointer is going
to go here our right pointer is going to
go here
clearly we go out of bounds though to
the left right so
so basically what we're saying is
there's only one substring where this is
the middle position of
and then we're going to do the same
thing for here so from this position we
want all sub strings where this
is the middle of so we're going to have
our left and right pointer initially
here
yes this character you know our left and
right pointer point at the same
character so we
we found one palindromic substring just
the single character itself
then we are going to take our left and
right pointers and then shift them so
left is going to go over here
right is going to go over here right so
now let's compare left character and
right character
since we already know this middle
portion
is a palindrome right now we only have
to compare the left and right characters
the new left and right characters if
they are equal right which they are a
equals a
right so therefore we found one
additional palindrome this palindrome of
length three
where this character is still the middle
position right so now we found an
additional palindrome so i think our
total number of palindromes is up to
three now
and once again we're going to take our
left pointer shift it to the left
right pointer and shift it to the right
now clearly once again our left pointer
goes out of bounds
so you know this is we can't really find
any more sub strings where this
is the middle position but do you notice
how
what we just did right we we cut down on
repeated work
we found that this is a substring and
then in another single operation we
found that this is a palindromic
substring as well
that cuts down on the repeated work
whereas before we would have done
something like okay
you know this is a polynomic substring
then we
increase it then we have to look at both
of these and
you know if we continue to increase it
if we go all the way here then we have
to still
check okay this is the same and now this
is the same right we're
continuing to do repeated work if we
start from the left and then expand to
the right but if we start in the middle
and expand left and right then we
eliminate repeated work
so let's do the same thing from here so
this is a palindromic substring right
left and right point at the same
character
then we expand once to the left once to
the right
are these characters the same right are
a
and b the same they're not the same so
we knew that the initial
substring just in the middle over here
the one the single character
was a palindrome but when we add this
character and this character it's no
longer a palindrome this is not a
palindrome so no matter what we do now
if i expand one more to the left and
expand one more to the right
even if these characters were the same
assume we had an a in both positions
it doesn't matter because the sub
problem the substring in the middle
is not a palindrome so therefore no more
substrings
expanded from the middle of this
position to the left and right
none of those additional substrings are
going to be palindromes
so so far our count of palindromes is at
four i believe so
now let's go to the last position so we
want to expand
from this middle position so we're gonna
go so initially we're gonna say okay
this itself is a palindrome so we can
change our count of palindromes to five
we try to expand left and we try to
expand right but again we go out of
bounds to the right side
so we're done so in total we found five
different
palindromes but it turns out we actually
missed a couple
we missed this palindrome of length two
and we missed this palindrome of length
two
how is it that we missed palindromes and
how is it that they're both
length two notice how we were starting
at each middle position
so this was a length of one right as we
add the adjacent positions then we're
increasing the palindrome
to length three and then if we added a
couple more we'd increase it to length
five so we're only
getting palindromes of odd length if we
want to get
palindromes of even lengths we have to
start
at every single even position so we'd
have to start
at here and then you know this is a
problem this is a substring of length
two and then we'd expand
by one more so then we'd get a
palindrome of length four and etcetera
etcetera just keep increasing it by two
so this is how we're going to get
palindromes of even length
so when we do this we're gonna have our
left pointer initialized here and
in this case the right pointer is
actually just gonna be left
plus one before we were doing it as left
and right both starting at the same
position in this case
left right is going to be left plus one
and so in this case we see
these characters are equal therefore
they are palindromes so we can increase
our count from five
to six we expand outwards left and right
but we see left is going to be out of
bounds
so then we can stop so next we're gonna
basically do the same thing for every
pair of adjacent characters right to
find even length palindromes so here
left and right are once again the same
so
we're gonna get our total to be seven
when we expand to the left and right
we see we have an a and we have a b
these characters are not the same so we
can't continue to expand and we don't
increment our result so now we have
seven palindromes this is the last even
length sub string that we're going to
start at and
the left and right characters are
clearly not the same so we don't
continue to expand and we don't
increment our result so
we're done with everything here we get a
result of seven
and the overall time complexity of doing
it like this
it's going to be big o of n because for
let's say the odd lengths
uh palindromes we're starting at every
single position
and potentially expanding outwards all
the way to the end of the string so
that's going to be
an end time operation so since we're
doing it for every single character in
the array it's going to be big o
n times n right so that's that's
basically how we're doing the odd length
palindromes and the
the same time complexity is going to be
true for even length right we're
basically going through every pair
of characters which there are you know
big o of n of them and then we're still
expanding outwards
so that's also going to be big o of n
times n now if you add these together
we're still going to get a overall time
complexity of big o
n squared so that's the overall time
complexity
in this solution and coding it up is
pretty easy so let's get into that
so let's keep track of a single result
variable and it's initially going to be
zero it's going to be the count
of the palindromic substrings so we want
to go through every single position
in the string s and expand from it right
that's going to give us the
odd length palindromes so we're going to
initialize our left
and right pointers both to be set to i
because these are odd length palindromes
and while
left is inbound so while left is greater
than or equal to zero
and right is inbound so right is less
than the length of the string
and this the position at left in our
string is equal to the position
at right in our string that means we
found a palindrome so let's
increment our result by one let's shift
our our left pointer to the left
and let's shift our right pointer to the
right and we're going to continue to do
that
while the pointers are in bounds and the
characters are the same then we're going
to continue to increment the number of
palindromes so that's going to give us
the palindromes of odd length we can we
don't have to do a separate for loop for
the even length palindromes let's just
do the exact same thing we've done up
above here
except in this case we're going to
initialize left to be
i which is what we did before but we're
going to initialize
right to be i plus 1
which is going to give us the even
length palindromes
and once we've done that we can
literally just copy and paste this for
loop up above
down here and then that'll calculate the
even length palindromes
and then once that is done we can go
ahead and return our result
now as you can see this solution works
that's the entire thing
it's very efficient but maybe your
interviewer will want you to
you know this is copy and paste and
sometimes they don't like copy and paste
we can
basically take these two and condense
them down into a single function
so i'm just going to do that even though
i'm sure you could probably figure out
how to do it in this case it's not too
bad so i'm going to make a function
called count palindromes and we'll pass
into
this the string s and the left
and right pointers that we are
initializing
and so basically what i'm going to do
here is take this and just copy and
paste it into here
right and so you can see that we're
giving this function the information it
needs we're giving it the string s we're
giving it pointers left and right
let's just give it a variable here let's
declare it result
is initially going to be 0 and then this
function is just going to return result
which is the number of palindromes it
can count
starting at these left and right
pointers so now we can
you know change this so here we're
trying to count the odd length
palindrome so
instead of doing this for loop we can
just say let's add to the result
the whatever this function returns so
count pally
passing in the string s passing in the
left pointer
and passing in the right pointer which
we just declared up above here
and getting rid of this while loop we
can do the same thing so
add to result whatever this function
returns count pali
passing in s passing in left
and passing in right and if we really
want we can take
left and replace it with i and right and
replace it with i
plus one so then we can get rid of these
two lines
and up above do the same thing so
replace left and right with both
i and then get rid of this line so this
is a pretty condensed
version of this function so with this
little helper function that we have we
can cut down on
that repeated code that we were writing
and basically get the same result
same efficiency same everything so i
hope that this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching